on the season finale of Rick and Morty
mr. president some kind of alien Booga
has infested the Kennedy sex tunnels
I wanted hunted down and taken out
Kennedy sex tunnels naturally you'll
forget you saw them along with in order
of national embarrassment the Truman
cocaine lounge the McKinley hooker dump
and the Lincoln slave Coliseum he didn't
free them all this seems like a good
time for a drink and a cold calculated
speech with sinister overtones but
speeches are for campaigning now is the
time for action
[Music]
hey everybody the Rick and Morty finale
is tonight and Dan Harmon supposedly
confirmed there would be some evil Morty
things happening he didn't say what
would be happening can we talk evil
Morty just wait until the end of the
season this Sunday at 11:30 p.m. on
Adult Swim that Easter Egg video will
post Monday morning so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything but it just
gives credence to the idea that the
description is very tongue-in-cheek and
in that it's misleading you through
omission like it just says rick has a
confrontation with the president so
there have been a couple different
presidents on Rick and Morty the
president of the lane government which
he met during the get schwifty episode
which we saw in the teaser so Keith
David's coming back it'll be awesome but
evil Morty is now the de facto president
of the Citadel of Rick's and we don't
know what his action is going to be like
he says now is the time for action it
even says action not words in Latin on
the board in the Morty's school so all
those Rick's that we saw pushing around
Morty's or yelling at them in the
classrooms they've all been taken out of
positions of authority and now a lot of
the Morty's are wearing the same
uniforms that Rick R so they just seems
like he's gearing up for some big power
play but it all goes back to the title
the Rick turian Morty date the idea you
know if you haven't seen that movie that
someone's put in the position of power
as a puppet so that they can turn over
power to another person so that doesn't
necessarily mean that the get schwifty
president is being controlled somehow
the way that the evil Rick was being
controlled by evil Morty way back during
season one but it does imply that the
googas that they're hired to take care
of in the kennedys sex tunnels is sort
of a misdirect for larger things that
are in play like something to get Rick
out of the way but if you've ever heard
that quote the greatest trick the devil
ever pulled was convincing the world he
didn't exist that sort of evil Morty's
charm and that only the council of ricks
knows what's going on like he killed
half of them because they were not bored
with his regime so unless they go
blabbing to everybody at the companies
or the organizations that they run
nobody knows that it's an evil Morty
that's in charge of the Citadel Rick
still hates them but there's this whole
platform of equality that evil Morty was
preaching that's how he played the sides
against each other we need to
work together but really he's using it
to bump up Morty's stock as a power play
- I think turn most Morty's against
their Rick's so think about what are
Morty's Ark has been this season it
seems like he's gotten smarter and
smarter taken more authority especially
because the parents have turned into
South Park style parents and they're all
acting like idiots so the kids actually
have to be the smart people me I tricked
Rick into taking dad on an adventure
because I thought I could get a break
from this kind of but no like father
like damn daughter you want to be like
Rick congratulations you're just as
arrogant and just as irresponsible god
damn it don't get paid enough for this
but wouldn't it be an amazing power play
if evil Morty were able to pull strings
in orchestrate events to turn our Morty
against our Rick so this is c-137 Rick
we still don't know which version of
Morty this is and obviously he already
told Beth that you're not my Beth so I
know everybody's still wondering who
evil Morty's original Rick was if he has
any connection to our c-137 Rick but I
think based on all the evidence they
presented this Morty is just a Morty who
remembers everything all the terrible
stuff that rick has done because the
minute that our Morty got all his
memories back he was so upset that he
drove right past killing Rick and wanted
to kill himself he's like I just can't
handle this this is ridiculous
everything is alive peace I'm out that's
even kind of the same type of speech
that Rick gave to Beth when he advised
her to just go off and paint a bow on
the universe am i evil worse you're
smart when you know nothing matters the
universe is yours and I've never met a
universe that was into it the universe
is basically an animal it grazes on the
ordinary creates infinite idiots just to
eat them
you know smart people get a chance to
climb on top take reality for a ride but
it'll never stop trying to throw you and
eventually it will there's no other way
off so there's a pretty powerful speech
speaking to his philosophy about life in
general like it's all relatively
meaningless and you keep trying to take
reality for a ride but eventually it
throws you so we sort of prophesying his
own demise but it's also sort of a hat
tip for evil Morty's eventual downfall -
he's also trying to take reality for a
ride like
there are a couple of people that rise
to that level like in this moment he's
mostly speaking to beth like she's risen
to the level where she's realized the
truth of the universe as rick believes
it go out there and do whatever the hell
you want to do because it doesn't mean
anything for as long as you can you can
always come back here but at some point
before we saw him way back during season
one evil morty also came to this
conclusion so that's probably why evil
Morty's so quick to throw these other
Morty's under the bus is that it doesn't
mean anything but rick is currently the
de facto power in the universe or the
multiverse depending on how you want to
think about it so the only real way to
take him down is to help get morty to
turn against him like he needs everybody
to turn against Rick and I know we have
Phoenix person too I included that clip
briefly because if they're bringing evil
Morty back in the finale then we might
also get a hat tip for Phoenix person in
tamii
because as far as we know they're not
working with evil Morty or they're not
being manipulated by evil Morty they're
part of the federation evil Morty is now
controlling the Citadel he could be
trying to take over the remnants of the
federation as well but just think about
the whole theme from back in episode 7
where you had two sides the Rick's and
the Morty's being played against each
other in evil morty trying to use that
to his advantage previously it was the
council of ricks versus the federation
so wouldn't it also be a big power play
for evil morty to unite those two
factions against our Rick so that would
be the back door for Phoenix person to
come back because as far as we know he's
still being controlled by Tammy so
technically he's evil Darth Vader style
but we all know how darth vader's arc
ended in regardless of what evil morty
does in the finale he's just too big of
a character and too interesting for them
to completely deal with in this episode
so i think that whatever he does he will
spill into season 4 he's like a Zebes
and fourth character just fantastic and
a good foil for Rick but obviously
because Stephen Colbert is so busy in
real life with the own television that
he's making he just doesn't have a lot
of time to come back and voice that
character again so conflict makes for
good drama and these characters make for
good conflict so I would be very
surprised if they don't make it to
season 4 but let me know in the comments
do you think that evil Morty is going to
be just a post-credits tag and we'll
have
nothing to do with the main plot of the
episode or do you think that he's going
to be orchestrating events from afar
starting to talk a little bit about
season 4 - I just learned that the
writers actually finished season 3 last
October
like literally last year they finished
writing all the scripts that we're
watching right now meaning that they
have probably been working on season 4
for a lot longer than we realized
so what will happen is is after I post
my finale video at some point I will do
a season 4 predictions video I'll talk a
little bit about where they are in
production and depending on how fast
they finish their scripts when they can
get episodes out it's sort of the
characters that they've left out that
they could bring back - I know everybody
wants to know where squanchy is there
are a couple of big characters that they
haven't officially brought back they
brought that mr. poopy butthole but in a
roundabout way they brought him back
into memory they brought him back in a
picture so he's still alive out there
somewhere we just don't know where but
it's gonna be awesome there'll be a new
round of the giveaway - all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video and I'll
still be doing that every week during
the offseason I'll explain the off
season bonus video schedule when I post
that finale video that'll be Monday
morning but why you wait for everything
you can click here for more Easter eggs
and you can click here for their finale
interview and a little bit more about
season 4 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]